Welcome everybody. Another exciting episode today. We're very excited with our guest here, Ronak, talking about two topics. Now, I watch some reality TV. I know I'm shameful. I'm not supposed to say that. And I watch that Top Chef and they always fuss, don't try to do two dishes because you're going to screw one of them up. Hopefully, that won't be us today. We're going to do two topics that are going to be pretty interesting and exciting. The first one, super, super relevant to everyone, developer burnout, but then also infrastructure as code, how they relate, what it is. I think this is going to be a pretty awesome jam-packed episode.
欢迎大家。今天的节目又是一个令人兴奋的节目。我们非常高兴能邀请到嘉宾罗纳克（Ronak），和我们探讨两个话题。话说回来，我有时候会看一些真人秀节目。我知道这有点见不得人。我不该这么说的。我看了那个《顶级大厨》（Top Chef），他们总是在抱怨，千万别同时做两道菜，因为你肯定会搞砸其中一道。希望今天我们不会这样。我们要讨论的两个话题都非常有趣和吸引人。第一个是与每个人都超级、超级相关的开发者倦怠，然后还有基础设施即代码，它们之间有什么联系，以及它究竟是什么。我觉得这将是一期内容极为丰富、干货满满的精彩节目。
Welcome to the show, Ronak. Hey, guys. Thank you for having me. I'm excited to be here talking about topics that are interesting to me. And also, thank you, Patrick, for the cooking reference. I love cooking shows. Okay, well, okay, we can get sidetracked there. The forming chocolate sculptures one. I forgot what it was called, but that was my favorite.
欢迎来到节目，罗纳克。嘿，大家好。谢谢邀请我来。我很兴奋能在这里和大家聊聊这些让我感兴趣的话题。另外，帕特里克（Patrick），谢谢你提到的烹饪梗。我很喜欢烹饪节目。好吧，好吧，我们可能会扯远了。那个制作巧克力雕塑的节目。我忘了它叫什么了，但那是我最喜欢的。
The like French, okay. Yes, yes, it was the French and the amazing things they can do with the chocolate. Absolutely amazing. Oh, dear. Okay, yeah, we're definitely going to get sidetracked. And I'm going to be hungry. It's almost lunchtime here. The French and the amazing things they can do with the chocolate. Absolutely amazing. Oh, dear. Okay, we're definitely going to get sidetracked. And I'm going to be hungry. It's almost lunchtime here.
就像法国的那个，好吧。是的，是的，就是法国的节目，以及他们用巧克力能做出那么惊人的东西。真的太惊人了。哦，天哪。好吧，是的，我们绝对要扯远了。而且我要饿了。这里快到午饭时间了。法国的节目，以及他们用巧克力能做出那么惊人的东西。真的太惊人了。哦，天哪。好吧，我们绝对要扯远了。而且我要饿了。这里快到午饭时间了。
So, I'm distracted now. Ronak is Developer Relations Manager at Quali. And we traditionally start out the show, Ronak, by just sort of talking about how people got into tech and their kind of story, how they ended up where they are. So, why don't you talk maybe, like, do you remember what your first computer was or your first experience? Where did you build that passion? First of all, I want to say again, thank you for having me. I mean, think about the extreme privilege that I'm enjoying. I'm talking about something I care about. And you guys are asking me these questions. And you want to listen. I think this is all the human experience is about like wanting to be heard and listen. Yeah, I totally remember what got me
所以我现在分心了。罗纳克是夸里（Quali）公司的开发者关系经理。我们节目的传统通常是，罗纳克，先聊聊大家是怎么进入科技行业的，以及他们的故事，他们是如何走到今天的职位的。所以，你不妨聊聊，比如，你还记得你的第一台电脑是什么吗？或者你的第一次经历？你的这种热情是从哪里培养出来的？首先，我想再次说一声，谢谢邀请我。我是说，想想我正在享受这种极大的特权。我在谈论我关心的事。而你们在问我这些问题。你们还想听。我觉得这就是人类体验的全部意义——想要被倾听。是的，我完全记得我是怎么
into technology. And I'm hoping somebody on listening to this podcast will remember it. But my old man was a an engineer. And they were learning this cool thing called Fortran back in his days in the 70s and I mean it was like it was cutting edge right and to train the engineers they had them and I think I found this on eBay still they're like green and white manuals it's like a really skinny you know flexible manual and it's striped green and white in the front. And it's learning Fortran. And it basically looked like a math book on the inside. And I was seven years old where I pulled these down off the, I'm not kidding.
进入科技领域的。我希望听这个播客的人中也会有人记得。我老爸是个工程师。在70年代，他那个年代，他们正在学习一样很酷的东西叫Fortran，我的意思是，这就像是尖端技术，对吧？为了培训工程师，他们让他们——我想我还在eBay上找到过这个——那是绿白相间的说明书，这是一本真的很薄的、（你知道的）软装说明书，封面有绿白相间的条纹。那是用来学Fortran的。翻开里面，它基本上看起来就像一本数学书。我当时七岁，我把这些书从——我没开玩笑。
I pulled them off the, because I was so bored. I was like looking for more to read. And I read it and it looked just like math problems. So I started doing it and started writing out the exercises and whatever and my dad came home from from work and he was like what who wrote in my manuals and by the way this is right how did you do this yeah you know he didn't at first and do this and uh and and him being and so him being an ind dad, not very impressed easily. You know, the typical joke there is they give 99.9% approval.
我把它们从——因为我太无聊了。我好像在找更多书读。我读了它，它看起来就像数学题。所以我开始做这些练习，开始把练习写下来之类的。然后我爸爸下班回家，他说：“什么？谁在我的说明书上乱写？”顺便问一下，这是怎么写的？你是怎么做到的？”是的，你知道的，他一开始并没有……然后做这个。而且，而且，而且他是一个印度爸爸，没那么容易留下深刻印象。你知道，典型的笑话是他们只给99.9%的认可。
So you're always chasing that 0.1%. But he gave full approval then. And that sparked it. I was done. I was like, oh, I'm going to do this. I'm going to program. I'm going to create the next awesome. Yeah. So that's how I got started. That's a great story. Wow. I mean, I think there's a story there about
所以你总是在追求那剩下的0.1%。但那一次他给予了百分之百的认可。这就点燃了火花。我彻底陷进去了。我想，哦，我要做这个。我要编程。我要创造下一个了不起的东西。是的，这就是我开始的方式。真是个棒极了的故事。哇。我的意思是，我觉得这里面有一个关于
parenting and about like the balance between letting, giving approval, but also, also sometimes like asking more of your kids and like trying to make sure that they know that they got to push themselves. I, that's something I, as being a parent, I won't get on that outside topic either. But I mean, that's a that's a struggle. So I mean, that's awesome that it worked out that time. That's really cool. Yeah, that and also, I guess, I, you know, since you brought up parenting and whatnot, I should put a plug in for, you know, sometimes things work, you know, like with parenting, and apparently it worked out in this case, but also don't be afraid to seek the mental help, help that you may or may not need due to the parenting style. So you know, work on yourself. And that's great, because like, we're talking about developer burnout, another
育儿的故事，关于如何在给予认可之间保持平衡，但有时也对孩子提出更多要求，确保他们知道自己必须鞭策自己。作为父母，我——我不会扯到那个题外话上去。但我的意思是，那是一个挣扎。所以，我的意思是，那次成功了真是太棒了，真的很酷。是的，还有，我想，既然你提到了育儿之类的话题，我应该打个广告，你知道的，有时方法确实管用，就像育儿一样，显然这次成功了，但也不要害怕去寻求你可能需要或不需要的心理帮助，因为这种育儿方式可能会带来影响。所以，你知道的，完善你自己。这太棒了，因为正如我们所讨论的，开发者倦怠，另一个
stress related issue. So I think that'll tie really nicely in with what we're talking about and solving those, those potentially deep wounds from our so okay all right i mean wanting to talk about developer burn i mean everyone has that i mean this is something you know we were talking a little bit before the show i just very you're very passionate about you think a lot about i think that's awesome important to talk about maybe how you kind of that first experience you know obviously growing up kind of where did you get what was your kind of programming journey your tech journey however that kind of that first experience, you know, obviously growing up, kind of where did you get? What was your kind of programming journey, your tech journey, however that kind of went from there?
与压力相关的问题。所以我觉得这能和我们正在讨论的内容，以及解决我们内心深处那些潜在伤痕的话题完美结合。好吧，好吧，我的意思是想谈谈开发者倦怠，每个人都有这种感觉。这是你知道的，我们在节目开始前稍微聊过的一点，你对此非常充满热情，你思考了很多，我觉得这太棒了、太重要了。也许可以聊聊你是怎么有那种初体验的，显然在成长过程中，你是怎么接触到——你的编程之旅是怎样的？你的科技之旅，不管它是怎么从那里开始的？
And then, you know, kind of first starting to encounter this dreaded burnout. I love it. And I have a really good story on how that started. And I have to be careful not to mention any business names. Okay, so yeah yeah here we go all right uh so let's see if if our listeners can decode what i'm saying uh my first is not blueberry it started at blueberry it's um there is a uh a big software creator in the pac Northwest. And I was a young developer working there. And the rumor has it that burnout is a model built in to that corporate culture. But I was young and hungry. And I thought this was the best thing that ever happened to me job wise. And I was eager to do it. So I had no problem pulling in the the 12-hour work
然后，你知道的，什么时候开始遇到这种可怕的倦怠。我太喜欢这个了。我有一个特别棒的故事，讲这一切是怎么开始的。我必须小心，不要提到任何公司的名字。好吧，好吧，我们开始吧。好吧，让我们看看我们的听众能不能解码我说的话。我的第一次不是“蓝莓”（blueberry），它始于蓝莓。这是一个——在太平洋西北地区有一家大型软件开发商。我当时是一名在那儿工作的年轻开发者。有传言说，倦怠是那种企业文化中内置的一种模式。但我当时年轻，充满渴望。我以为这是我职业生涯中遇到的最好的事情。而且我非常渴望这样做。所以我每周工作12小时也毫无怨言。
days and um and it was amazing right first time uh you know out of college and these these big buildings working on problems that were uh important anyways uh I was leaving uh one night after you know just two months of doing this and I made friends with the security guard who actually decided to chew the fat with me and walk to the parking lot with me, the parking structure. And I asked the security guard, hey, what's up with that Prius in the corner? And I think anybody from this time period will know this story. And there was just this Prius gathering dust, had all flat tires, totally covered in dust. And the security guard told me, well, that's actually a person who's been working here for a year now, hasn't left.
而且这太棒了，对吧？刚毕业，在这些大楼里工作，处理的都是重要的问题。不管怎样，在一个晚上，在干了仅仅两个月后，我下班了。我和一个保安交了朋友，他居然决定跟我闲聊，陪我一起走到停车场，走到那个停车楼。我问那个保安：“嘿，角落里那辆普锐斯（Prius）是怎么回事？”我想那个时期的任何人都会知道这个故事。那辆普锐斯落满了灰尘，四个轮胎全瘪了，完全被灰尘覆盖。保安告诉我：“哦，那其实是一个在这里工作了一年、至今没离开过的人的车。”
And he got a call from his now ex-girlfriend saying to come and pick his stuff up because he no longer lives there. And his stuff in the Pacific Northwest was just sitting outside soaking in the rain. And he discovered that he no longer has a life there. And he just brought his car back and parked it there and just stayed working. Wait, we got to double click on this. So where does this person sleep? I mean, how does this work functionally?
他接到他现在已经是前女友的电话，叫他去把他的东西拿走，因为他再也不住在那里了。他在太平洋西北地区的那些东西就堆在外面泡在雨里。他发现自己在那儿已经没有生活可言了。于是他把车开回来停在那儿，然后就一直留在公司工作。等等，我们得深入八卦一下。这个人睡在哪儿？我的意思是，这在功能上是怎么运作的？
Okay, let me tell you, all the things that end up contributing to developer burnout actually seem really cool at the beginning. And I'll give an example. My kid, my 14-year-old loves his smartphone. We just gave it to him. But all of us adults know that smartphone is like the work of the devil, right? And you try to hide it away from you as much as possible. So I thought it was cool as a young software developer that there is kitchens filled with large industrial refrigerators full of all the food you can want. You know, I just opened my backpack and just put them all in because super poor. And they had massage chairs and quiet rooms. And we all did have our important office.
好吧，我告诉你，所有最终导致开发者倦怠的事情，在一开始看起来都真的非常酷。我举个例子。我的孩子，我14岁的儿子很喜欢他的智能手机。我们刚送给他的。但我们这些成年人都知道智能手机简直就是魔鬼的化身，对吧？你会尽量把它藏得远远的。所以作为一个年轻的软件开发商，我曾觉得很酷的是，那里有装满大型工业冰箱的厨房，里面塞满了你想要的各种食物。你知道的，我只需要打开背包把它们全都装进去，因为当时超级穷。他们还有按摩椅和静音室。而且我们确实都有我们重要的办公室。
I think you're getting, Jason, the answer to this question is that developer slept in his office. And by the way, that was totally okay. Yeah. Wow, that is wild. Yeah, I feel it's worth giving some context there that I mean, people have heard the stories about other companies. And yeah, you like you mentioned,
我想你已经得到答案了，杰森（Jason），这个问题的答案是：那个开发者就睡在办公室里。顺便说一句，这完全是可以接受的。是的。哇，太疯狂了。是的，我觉得有必要提供一些背景信息，人们都听过关于其他公司的故事，是的，就像你提到的，
free food, free meals. They're also often I mean, maybe you don't know this. I was explaining to someone in my family, this is a thing that I made a joke about staying in the office. I didn't, but I made a joke, I could just live there. And they're like, what? And I'm like, yeah, there are showers, because people bike in. And so there are showers. You could shower. You could have stuff. You have an office or a quiet room where you could easily nap at night when no one's there. And there are stories, both probably real and not so real, of people just living in the office and it not being the worst thing. Like people kind of go, Oh yeah, I could see doing that. It makes a sense. And especially when you couple it with how expensive it is in a lot of these places to live. Now you say you can actually justify it, right?
免费食物，免费大餐。它们也经常——也许你不知道。我曾向我的一位家人解释过，这是我开玩笑说要留在办公室的一件事。我没有真的留宿，但我开玩笑说我可以直接住在那里。他们问：“什么？”我说：“对啊，那里有淋浴间，因为有人骑自行车上班。所以有淋浴间。你可以洗澡。你可以有各种东西。你有一个办公室或者静音室，晚上没人的时候你可以在那里轻松打个盹。”而且有很多故事，可能真有其事，也可能是虚构的，说有人就直接住在办公室里，而且这也不是最糟糕的事。人们会觉得：“哦，是的，我能理解这么做。这说得通。”特别是当你把这一点与其中许多地方高昂的生活成本结合起来时。现在你说你实际上可以为此辩护，对吧？
It's not that the person is broken. It's that they're smart and they're smart because they've, they've killed their commute. They don't have to do it anymore. They don't have to pay for a home. And you can actually begin to put this person on a pedestal. And the same happens with now the thing is people getting those big vans, the conversion vans, and parking them in the parking lot. Oh, I don't live in the office. I travel around in my van. But it's there when you leave, and it's there when you get back. I want to just kind of key in on, you know, what,
不是说这个人崩溃了，而是说他们很聪明，而且他们很聪明，因为他们省去了通勤时间。他们不必再忍受通勤了。他们不必支付房租。你实际上可以开始把这个人奉上神坛。现在的情况也是一样，人们买那些大面包车，改装面包车，然后把它们停在停车场里。“哦，我不住在办公室。我开着我的房车四处旅行。”但当你离开时它就在那儿，当你回来时它也依然在那儿。我想把重点放在——你知道的，
what Patrick was saying, though, that shook me, you know, the actual, it was a rumor seeing that car and people, but the actual, you know, parking lot, the security guard, the attendant telling me that story and confirming it. And, you know, I don't know if it's true, because I never met the gentleman, but it was a compelling enough, it was real enough, I could see the burnout in my group. And it actually scared me. And that was, you know, about 20 years ago, and I sort of took it as a cautionary, like a scared straight type of tale. I was, I did not want to be like that. I didn't want to work so hard on something that, you know, I didn't care whether all my stuff was sitting outside, getting right. I mean, it, I didn't want to be
帕特里克刚才说的话上，那震撼了我，你知道的，实际上，那只是关于看到那辆车和那些人的传言，但实际上，你知道的，停车场，保安，服务员告诉我那个故事并证实了它。而且，你知道的，我不知道这是不是真的，因为我从来没见过那位先生，但它足够引人入胜，足够真实，我能看到我们团队里的倦怠情绪。这确实吓到我了。那是，你知道的，大约20年前，我有点把它当成一个警示，就像一个“吓得你走正路”的故事。我，我不想变成那样。我不想为某种东西拼命工作，你知道的，以至于我根本不在乎我所有的东西都堆在外面淋雨。我的意思是，我不想变成
like that. And that's what started me on this path thinking, you know, I, in fact, I was lucky, I had an experience early on in my career, instead of, you know, like the lobster slowly boiling in the water and not realizing that they're in harm, I had a quick shock. And I started looking for signs of this. And you can see it in the interview, when the interview, if they ever call their team a family, I think, come on, us being in IT, we know what family means. We're going to get a call for every computer problem that the family has. Yeah. So I kind of look out for those keywords and I've been trying to avoid it. So first step in the Maslow's hierarchy is survival. But next I'm, I'm privileged enough and I work for people good enough. How do I help others? Yeah. I mean, I think there's some, I mean, we could kind of take it
那样。这就是让我开始走上这条路的契机，我想，你知道的，事实上我很幸运，我在职业生涯的早期就经历过这一切，而不是像慢慢在水里煮沸的龙卷风——哦不，是龙虾——不知道自己身处险境，我经历了一次快速的冲击。我开始寻找这方面的迹象。你可以在面试中看出来，如果面试时他们把团队称为“一家人”，我想，拜托，身在IT界的我们都知道“一家人”意味着什么。这意味着我们要接听这个“家庭”遇到的每一个电脑问题的求助电话。所以我会留意这些关键词，我一直在努力避开它。因此，马斯洛需求层次理论的第一步是生存。但接下来，我很幸运，而且我为足够好的人工作。我该如何帮助别人？是的。我的意思是，我觉得有一些——我们可以从两个方面来看待它。
from both sides. I think you're already mentioning sort of recognizing the signs. And I actually really liked that you, in some ways, made it an analogy to a cell phone, where I think the belief that it's a strictly positive or negative thing, I don't want to say it's a naive belief, but the black and white part of it is not, I know where you were going. But I mean, I think this, the companies, I don't know that they intend to make it a trap, but they don't not intend to do it either. Oh, see, there we got the double negative going. No, you're awesome. I love that, actually. Yeah. And so I think like, you know, there's a story about you know video game developers and they're they're working hard to push out you know before the deadline and there's there's you know people
我觉得你已经提到了识别这些迹象。而且我真的很喜欢你把它比作手机，在某种程度上，我认为人们认为它纯粹是一件好事或坏事，我不想说这是一种天真的看法，但非黑即白的观点是不对的，我知道你要说什么。但我的意思是，我认为这些公司，我不知道他们是不是有意把它变成一个陷阱，但他们也不是无意这么做的。噢，看，这里我们用了双重否定。不，你太棒了。其实我很喜欢这样。是的，所以我觉得，你知道的，有一个关于电子游戏开发者的故事，他们在截止日期前拼命赶工，而且你知道的，有人
install bunk beds because you know hey we're just going to crash here at least we have a place to sleep management realizes the problem what's the solution the solution is take away the bunk beds and it's like wait a minute right and so i, I don't want to demonize the companies completely yet. Well, and that's not productive, too. We are, I'm not here to, like, deep dive into or create like a, you know, a sort of political social justice moment here, but there's things that we can do, like, you know, understanding both ends of the equation. And let's try to understand that corporate position. All right. We're, we are here to make money. And in the, you know, our salary isn't a, isn't a charity, you know, type of thing. It's, it's a trade off our time for them to get a product. Now, I think both sides have a room to understand the other, sometimes in blindly chasing
安装了双层床，因为“嘿，我们今晚就在这儿过夜吧，至少我们有个睡觉的地方”。管理层意识到了这个问题，解决方案是什么？解决方案是把双层床撤走。这就有点像——等等，对吧？所以，我不想完全把这些公司妖魔化。好吧，那也没有建设性。我们，我不是来这里深入探讨或制造某种政治社会正义时刻的，但有些事情我们可以做，比如，理解等式两端。让我们试着理解企业的立场。好吧，我们，我们来这里是为了赚钱。而且在，你知道的，我们的薪水不是慈善施舍。它是一种权衡，我们付出时间，他们得到产品。现在，我觉得双方都有空间去了解对方，有时在盲目追逐
profits and features. And, you know, the next thing, we sometimes don't know about, like the long term costs. And I'm here to talk about, and we're going to get into IAC here in a sec. I'm here to talk about how it is in corporations' interest to sort of, I want to say nip this in the bud, but to address developer burnout. Because at the end of the day, and I want to speak the language to our corporate system, is that we need to address this so that we can be more profitable and that we have a better long-term outlook. Turning over one skilled employee, forget about the morale. It just doesn't make business sense.
利润和功能时，你知道的，下一个目标，我们有时会忽略长期成本。我来这里是为了讨论——我们一会儿就会聊到IAC。我来这里是为了讨论，为什么企业有动力去——我想说把这苗头扼杀在萌芽状态，但实际上是去解决开发者倦怠问题。因为归根结底——我想用我们的企业系统的语言来说——我们需要解决这个问题，这样我们才能获得更高的盈利能力，并拥有更好的长期前景。流失一个熟练的员工，抛开士气不谈，这从商业角度来看根本说不通。
It costs so much to onboard and make it. You know, in my field, a lot of times, especially like, say, things like consultant or implementation engineer or public facing technologists, it can take up to a year to make them productive. You know, that's very expensive. I can, we can do things to address developer burnout. And I kind of wanted to talk about some of that. I don't want to veer too far. But I have hope that we can use technology to fulfill some of that. I don't want to veer too far, but I have hope that we can use technology to fulfill some of that promise on both sides. Yeah, that's a good call out. I think one of the things related to burnout that shocked me was how
入职培训和培养一名员工的成本太高了。你知道，在我的领域，很多时候，特别是像顾问、实施工程师或面向公众的技术人员，可能需要长达一年的时间才能让他们产生生产力。你知道，这非常昂贵。我能——我们可以采取措施解决开发者倦怠。我有点想谈谈其中的一些。我不想偏离太远。但我抱有希望，我们可以利用技术来兑现一部分这样的承诺。我不想偏离太远，但我抱有希望，我们可以利用技术来兑现双方的一部分承诺。是的，这切中要害。我觉得与倦怠相关的一件让我感到震惊的事情是，
different disciplines have different ways that they get burned out. So for example, if you're in sales, you're on the phone a lot. And so if your manager calls you to give you some immediate feedback, that's actually a great thing. I mean, most people love to get feedback. They don't get enough of it. And when they get a call from their manager just impromptu, hey, you know, I was in that call with you five minutes ago, and I think you did a great job. That is just net positive, right? But engineers really value their sort of flow time, their sort of individual kind of focus time. And so that's an example where, you know, a manager who isn't in tune with developers, you know, might just randomly pick up the phone and call a developer and say, hey, you did a great job. And they don't realize that now it's going to take 30 minutes to get back that context to get back into that code. And so there's a lot of pitfalls like that
不同的学科有不同的倦怠方式。例如，如果你从事销售工作，你经常要打电话。所以如果你的经理打电话给你，给你一些即时反馈，这其实是一件好事。我的意思是，大多数人喜欢得到反馈。他们得到的反馈还不够。当他们接到经理的即兴电话时，“嘿，你知道，我五分钟前和你一起参加了那个通话，我觉得你做得真棒。”这绝对是纯粹的正效益，对吧？但工程师非常珍视他们的心流时间，也就是他们个人的专注时间。所以这就是一个例子，一个不了解开发者的经理可能会随机拿起电话给开发者打电话，说：“嘿，你做得真棒。”他们没有意识到，现在需要30分钟才能恢复那个上下文，重新进入代码状态。所以，当你管理开发者时，有很多这样的陷阱，
when you're managing developers that people aren't aware of. I love that, actually. I love what Jason just said, because, well, and let's talk about even lots of people like being managed differently, you know, sales versus development, and even how we get feedback. You know, yes, I'm more, as you guys can probably tell, I'm more of a people person, you know, but not a lot of my colleagues are. And picking up that phone call from manager might be, in addition to, as mentioned, the contact switching, which is, by the way, just incredibly annoying to contact switch. But it might also increase my social anxiety. I don't want to have this conversation with. But that's not to say developers don't like feedback. And so we have
人们并没有意识到。其实我很喜欢这样。我很喜欢杰森刚刚说的话，因为，好吧，我们甚至可以谈谈很多人喜欢被不同地管理，你知道的，销售与开发，甚至我们如何获得反馈。你知道，是的，正如你们可能看出来的，我更是一个擅长人际交往的人，你知道的，但我很多同事并不是。接听经理的电话除了前面提到的上下文切换——顺便说一句，上下文切换简直烦人得要命——之外，还可能会增加我的社交焦虑。我不想和他们进行这种对话。但这并不是说开发者不喜欢反馈。所以我们在
in development, most software gets created through what's known as a CICD pipeline, continuous integration, continuous deployment, or as I like to call it, everything. The idea is software should be built like five minutes ago. They just want you to think it, have it coded, and then appear out in the world as continuous deployment. That's where we're getting to. And to do that, a developer needs feedback, constant feedback, but they want it in channels they can subscribe to. Maybe I have a Slack integration, or I have an email that the build delivers, and I get that feedback. I can choose when to get that feedback, you know, and it's not human, so it's predictable.
开发中，绝大多数软件都是通过所谓的CI/CD流水线（持续集成、持续部署）创建的，或者正如我喜欢叫它的那样——一切。其核心思想是，软件应该在五分钟前就构建好。他们只是想让你构思好，编写好代码，然后作为持续部署突然出现在世界上。这就是我们正在努力的方向。为了做到这一点，开发者需要反馈，不断的反馈，但他们希望反馈来自他们可以订阅的渠道。也许我有一个Slack集成，或者构建会发送一封电子邮件，我通过它获得反馈。我可以选择什么时候接收这些反馈，你知道的，它不是人类，所以它是可预测的。
You know, it's a predictable piece of feedback versus a lot of times I may be a more introverted person and that social interaction through a phone call, that saps me out. There's something called spoon theory too and some people only have a certain amount of spoons they can give to social interaction and we should be mindful of that too especially in the developer community folks are going into this not because they want to you know be people facing a lot of times you know know? Yeah, I think recognizing and various companies try to give
你知道的，这是一种可预测的反馈，而很多时候我可能是一个更内向的人，通过电话进行的社交互动会榨干我的精力。还有一个叫“汤匙理论”（spoon theory）的概念，有些人只有一定数量的“汤匙”（精力）可以分配给社交互动，我们也应该注意到这一点，特别是在开发者社区中，人们进入这个行业往往不是因为他们想经常抛头露面，你知道的？是的，我认为认识到这一点，并且各种公司试图提供
various trainings on like, recognizing that there are different different folks. But in practice, it's something that I think you just always have to work at that empathy, putting yourself in other people's shoes and realizing the way you view the world isn't necessarily universally subscribed to. And I mean, even today, you know, I don't want to get into the like politics in the workplace. And we've seen a lot of people pushing for either more or less. And I mean, I think there's a lot of stuff that happens at work. And add that to your personal life, like we saw during COVID, where now like, not only is there people being worried, people are being different kinds of worried, people are having different ways they want to talk about how they want to deal with being
各种培训来——认识到存在不同类型的人。但在实践中，我觉得你必须一直致力于培养这种同理心，设身处地为他人着想，并意识到你对世界的看法并不一定被普遍认同。我的意思是，甚至在今天，你知道的，我不想谈论职场政治。我们看到很多人在推动更多或更少的工作。我的意思是，职场上发生了很多事情。再加上你的个人生活，就像我们在新冠疫情期间看到的那样，现在不仅有人感到担忧，人们还以各种不同的方式担忧，人们对于如何处理这种担忧和问题有不同的交流方式，对吧？所有这些东西交织在一起，你最终会得到这样的结果：“嘿，有人在我的视频里看到了我的家里，而我的家过去是一个不需要工作的地方，对吧？”有些人认为工作就是工作，非工作就不是工作。另一些人的界限则比较模糊。我认为，有时候通过
worried and about the problem, right? And it's just all this stuff swirls and you end up with this, you know, hey, I have someone on video in my house and my house used to be the place where it wasn't work, right? And some people have this work is work and, you know, not work is not work. Other people have a more blurry line. And I think that, you know, sometimes through, you know, intentional or unintentional processes, those lines blur. And you were kind of mentioning, you know, some things to deal with it. But for me, what I'll say is, I think,
有意或无意的过程，这些界限变得模糊了。你刚才提到了应对这种情况的一些方法。但对我来说，我想说的是，
having in your mind, like, what is work and what is work to you, and having it be defined is one of those critical things where it's okay, if you want to work at some place, because you believe it's changing the world. And it's the only thing that matters. But be very clear to yourself that that's your relationship. If it's just a paycheck, be clear to yourself that it's just a paycheck, right? Like in your own mind, at least, be clear your relationship to this job. Because if you don't, you end up with this murky, like, what is the right thing to tell your boss when they call you on the weekend? Or if you know, you get a text message at 3am and get fussed at, you didn't respond to it. And so, you know, you got to have talking about being clear on that i mean basically we're talking about uh boundary setting and and and there's two parts like we we started this um
在你的脑海里，明确什么是工作，什么是对你来说的工作，并给它下个定义，这是至关重要的事之一。如果你因为相信某个地方正在改变世界而想在那里工作，那也没问题。而且这是唯一重要的事情。但你要非常清楚地告诉自己，这就是你与它的关系。如果它只是一份薪水，也要清楚地告诉自己，它只是一份薪水，对吧？至少在你自己心里，要清楚你与这份工作的关系。因为如果不这样做，你最终就会陷入这种模棱两可的状态，比如：当老板在周末打电话给你时，什么是正确的回应？或者，如果你知道自己在凌晨3点收到一条短信，却因为没有回复而被责备。所以，你知道的，我们要明确这一点，基本上我们谈论的是——边界设定。而且有两个部分——我们以这个开头：
podcast out on not villainizing any one group i mean i think um i think at the end of the day you're going to realize it's like i mean we're not so far apart the developers and the management we're not far but we actually have the same goal. Believe it or not, developers, they absolutely, 100%, they're going into the work and they want, no developer says like, oh, I want to accomplish less today. No, it's very important that they accomplish the thing that they accomplish. And it's just that it becomes, so developer burnout, I feel is a just a fancy term for any type of burnout. And that burnout is you have burnout when you're in a situation and you're unable to manage the stress in that situation. And then that accumulates over time, and then you have something burnout. Sorry, if I'm explaining this to and everybody has the same idea but i just want to start off as that baseline and i wanted to talk about something i'm hopeful about so so far we've been talking about bad and and whatnot but we have
我们没有把任何一个群体妖魔化。我的意思是，我觉得，到头来你会发现，我们其实并没有相差那么远，开发者和管理层，我们并不遥远，我们实际上有着相同的目标。信不信由你，开发者们，他们绝对、100%地投入到工作中，他们希望——没有哪个开发者会说：“哦，我今天想少完成一点工作。”不，完成他们所做的事情是非常重要的。只是它变成了——所以开发者倦怠，我觉得这只是任何类型倦怠的一个花哨的术语。所谓的倦怠，就是当你处于某种情境中，且无法管理该情境中的压力时，压力就会随着时间推移而累积，然后你就会出现某种倦怠。抱歉，如果我是在向大家解释这个大家都懂的概念，但我只是想以这个作为基线，我想谈谈一些让我感到希望的事情。到目前为止，我们一直在谈论糟糕的事情等等，但我们
things have improved right i mean um you know the uh the pandemic has been terrible, but it has given us opportunities, you know, for instance, to increase our remote productivity, right? Zoom and all the connectivity there. And I wanted to talk about, if it's okay, something that's helpful that I see as for the first time, you know, we're now at the place in our CICD pipeline is the pipeline that software gets built in. And, you know, I've been at a couple of DevOps conferences where, you know, some folks say the CICD pipeline is the meeting place for all interested to get, it's like the meeting place where we have to communicate with each other. Developers are now forced. It's like where the rubber meets the road where I finished a feature, management says, okay, where's that feature? It's going to happen through that CI CD pipeline. That's where we're
事情已经有所改善了，对吧？我的意思是，你知道的，大流行虽然很糟糕，但它确实为我们提供了机会，比如，提高我们的远程生产力，对吧？Zoom和那里的所有连接。如果可以的话，我想谈谈一些有帮助的事情，这是我第一次看到，你知道的，我们现在正处于CI/CD流水线的位置，流水线是构建软件的地方。而且，你知道的，我参加过几次DevOps会议，有些人说CI/CD流水线是所有利益相关者的聚会场所，它就像是我们必须互相交流的聚会场所。开发者现在被迫参与。这就像是理论付诸实践的地方：我完成了一个功能，管理层说：“好的，那个功能在哪里？”这将会通过那个CI/CD流水线发生。这就是我们
sort of saying it's okay to communicate versus picking up the phone. And within that pipeline, an activity that happens is when you develop software, it has to be deployed somewhere. And that deployment place is called, it's infrastructure. And in more general, it's called an environment. That is like, I think the, you know, Star Trek, the final frontier of automation or not final, but it's the next frontier of automation within that pipeline. And why do we care about that automation?
所说的可以交流的地方，而不是拿起电话。在那个流水线中，有一项活动是，当你开发软件时，它必须被部署到某个地方。那个部署的地方被称为基础设施。更宽泛地说，它被称为环境。这就像是，我认为，你知道的，星际迷航中的自动化最终前沿，或者说不是最终前沿，但它是该流水线中自动化的下一个前沿。我们为什么关心这种自动化？
It's because it's less tedious crap that I have to do. And leading the way for the first time, we have the popularization, and we couldn't do this before, but we have something called infrastructure as code. People like Terraform, folks like the Helm chart, for instance, we're taking the tedium of standing up a server. And you can see where this trend has gone. At first, I remember when I was a young IT engineer that we would rack and stack servers and we would have a cold room with raised floors, right? I was
因为这减少了我必须做的那些沉闷烦人的破事。作为开路先锋，我们第一次迎来了普及，而我们以前是做不到这一点的，我们有了一种叫做“基础设施即代码”的东西。像Terraform这样的人，像Helm chart这样的人，我们正在消除搭建服务器的繁琐工作。你可以看到这个趋势的发展方向。起初，我记得当我年轻的时候，作为一个IT工程师，我们会把服务器上架堆叠，我们会有带有高架地板的冷室，对吧？我当时
working at a large gas firm at a large oil company in Houston, Texas, not hard to imagine. And we had cold rooms on every floor, you know, of the building. And I walked into a cold room with a team, we're supposed to do some wiring and rack up a new test environment. This is how hard it was. It would take weeks to get an environment, which is just a group of servers in together and wired and put in the right subnet and whatever. All of that was manual.
在德克萨斯州休斯顿的一家大型天然气公司、一家大石油公司工作，这不难想象。我们大楼的每一层都有冷室。我和一个团队走进一个冷室，我们本要做一些布线，并组装一个新的测试环境。这有多难呢？获取一个环境需要数周时间，环境只是一组连在一起、布好线、放入正确子网等等的服务器。所有这些都是手动的。
And we go to, you know how you lift the raised floor tiles under it. It's with suction cups, right? Have you seen those suction cups? Well, you gotta probably explain to people what cold rooms are. Like, I mean, I know what it is. I've been in them, but there are probably so many people out here
我们去——你知道你是怎么掀起高架地板砖的吗？是用吸盘，对吧？你见过那些吸盘吗？好吧，你可能得向人们解释什么是冷室。我的意思是，我知道那是什么。我进去过，但外面可能还有很多人
like, what are you talking about? Refrigerator? You're so right. So a cold room is before you had your cloud and your Amazon, everybody would have, I feel like a grandfather explaining this to like back in my days. I totally am. Back in the old days, what you do is instead of cloud, you would have a
会问：“你在说什么？冰箱吗？”你太对了。所以冷室就是，在你有云和亚马逊（Amazon）之前，每个人都会——我感觉自己像个爷爷在跟人说“在我那个年代”。我完全就是这样。在过去的旧时光里，你不会用云，而是会有一个
server room, which is all the cloud is, right? It's like a giant server room and people are taking bits of those technology. But back in the day, everybody had their own lab room where all of these servers were being underutilized and set up into environments that you could connect to before somebody had the good idea of, oh, let's put these in a common location and serve them out as a cloud. So you'd have your own personal cold room, which is just servers and racking and cooling all in one place for you to access compute power we didn't call it then we said hey we need a server in in the lab uh so you in and you raise the floor because a lot of times you put these in old buildings and uh it's to allow
服务器机房，云不也就是这个吗？它就像一个巨大的服务器机房，人们在享用这些技术的碎片。但在过去，每个人都有自己的实验室机房，里面所有的服务器都未被充分利用，并被设置为各种环境，供你在有人想出那个好主意之前进行连接——“哦，让我们把这些放在一个公共位置，作为云提供出去”。所以你会拥有自己的个人冷室，它只是把服务器、机架和冷却集中在一个地方，供你访问计算能力——我们当时不这么叫，我们说：“嘿，我们需要实验室里的一台服务器。”所以你走进去，掀起地板，因为很多时候你把这些装在老旧的建筑里，这是为了让
cooling and all the wiring to go under and it literally is cold they blow like extra air conditioning in it because the servers get hot and they don't want them to overheat yeah yeah go in with a jacket type of thing right and i uh took suction cups and i attempted to or i did lift the the panel on the floor that we were going through and we found curled up a contractor asleep. We found a contractor. I'm not a narc, but this is a definite situation that's not tenable or safe.
冷却和所有的布线从下面通过。而且它字面意义上真的很冷，他们会吹额外的空调进去，因为服务器会变热，他们不希望服务器过热。是的，是的，进去得穿夹克那种地方，对吧？我——我拿着吸盘，试图或者确实掀起了我们要通过的那块地板砖，然后我们发现里面蜷缩着一个睡觉的承包商。我们发现了一个承包商。我不是个告密者，但这绝对是一个站不住脚或不安全的情况。
This was reported and we never saw that contractor again, but some people address developer burnout in different ways, I guess. You never saw him again, but you always felt like he was there just underfoot i it was a creepy i'm so glad i've looked all the tiles now whenever you go in you gotta put like clear ones in i try to never be in a cold room anymore it's kind of like one of those things like from your early on in your career, it's like,
这件事被举报了，我们再也没有见过那个承包商，但我想，有些人会用不同的方式来应对开发者倦怠。你再也没有见过他，但你总觉得他就一直在那儿，就在脚底板下面。这太毛骨悚然了。我很庆幸现在我把所有的地砖都看了一遍。每当你进去的时候，你都得放透明的地板砖。我尽量再也不去冷室了。这有点像那种你职业生涯早期经历的事情，就像是，
oh, yeah, I'm never doing that again. But yes, now I'm always afraid. Okay, so sorry, gentlemen, I got off track. Thank you. So we have now something. So I was describing the dinosaur days, right? What I want to describe now is we've come to where nobody has a cold room in their office. They use Amazon or Azure or whatever.
哦，是的，我再也不做那个了。但是是的，现在我总是害怕。好吧，抱歉，各位先生，我扯远了。谢谢。所以我们现在有了一些——所以我刚才是在描述恐龙时代的经历，对吧？我现在想描述的是，我们已经到了这样一个地步：没有人会在办公室里设冷室。他们使用亚马逊、微软云（Azure）或者其他什么。
They're a cloud service, right? And it used to be you can create these infrastructure components through the GUI, but nobody does that anymore either. They provision out systems through code. And a lot of these cloud providers have their own language. But what's cool about something like Terraform is they're cloud agnostic. Meaning I can code up, I can say, stand up a Tomcat server, stand up a load balancer, stand up a database in this one script, and I can point it to AWS or Azure or whatever, and my assets will appear after I run this script, right? Doesn't that sound like a miracle?
它们是云服务，对吧？过去你可以通过图形用户界面（GUI）创建这些基础设施组件，但现在也没有人那样做了。他们通过代码来配置系统。许多这样的云服务提供商都有自己的语言。但像Terraform这样的工具酷就酷在它们是与云无关的。这意味着我可以编写代码，我可以写道：“在这个脚本中启动一个Tomcat服务器，启动一个负载均衡器，启动一个数据库”，我可以把它指向AWS或Azure或其他什么，当我运行这个脚本后，我的资产就会出现，对吧？这听起来是不是像个奇迹？
You know, yeah, it sounds like now I don't have to do anything to get this, you know, server. I don't have to rack it. I don't have to provision it. I don't have to go to a GUI to do it. And it's all within command line tools. And I'm arguing that things like that can remove, probably folks that are listening right now have had trouble with an environment. They need an environment to deploy their software. They're ready to go. The corporate managers and leadership are saying, this is great.
你知道的，是的，听起来现在我不需要做任何事情就能得到这个服务器。我不需要把它上架。我不需要配置它。我不需要通过图形用户界面去做。这一切都在命令行工具中完成。而我的观点是，诸如此类的事情可以消除——现在正在听节目的朋友们可能都遇到过环境方面的问题。他们需要一个环境来部署他们的软件。他们已经准备好了。企业经理和领导层说：“这太棒了。”
And we're realizing right now that the bottleneck is somewhere to install that software. So infrastructure as code gets us one step closer to the promised land where I don't have to worry about that. Immediately after building my code, so the current process is check out code from like a source control, right? Onto your build server. That's a well-understood pattern. You build the code into bits that you can deploy.
我们现在意识到，瓶颈在于安装该软件的某个环节。所以“基础设施即代码”让我们离承诺的土地更近了一步，在那里我不必担心这个问题。在构建代码之后，当前的流程是从源代码管理中检出代码，对吧？放到你的构建服务器上。这是一个广为人知的模式。你将代码构建为你可以部署的二进制片段。
Also well-understood, very well mature. You save the bits onto an artifact repository, which is a binary repository, similar to source control, but stores a version of your software. That's well-understood. And automation deployment is also well understood. We get it from that commonplace, the artifact repository and install
同样广为人知，非常成熟。你将这些片段保存到构件仓库（artifact repository）中，这是一个二进制仓库，类似于源代码管理，但存储的是软件的版本。这是广为人知的。自动化部署也是广为人知的。我们从那个公共地方——构件仓库获取并安装
our systems. What we're still in the baby nation phase of is having that environment codified to be consistent and to be on demand and ready. And infrastructure as code is that next thing I'm super excited about that really is going to help developers not sit around and wait ever for that. We can find the next bottleneck. So yeah, we can go as deep as you want there. So let's talk. Today's sponsor is Mergify.
我们的系统。我们仍处于婴儿期的部分是，使该环境规范化，做到一致、按需且就绪。“基础设施即代码”就是我超级兴奋的下一件事，它真的会帮助开发者不再无所事事地等待。我们可以寻找下一个瓶颈。所以，是的，我们可以按你的要求深入探讨。那么，我们来聊聊。今天的赞助商是Mergify。
Mergify is a tool for GitHub that prioritizes, tunes, automatically merges, comments, rebases, updates, labels, backports, closes, and assigns your pull requests. Mergify features allow you to automate what you would normally do manually. You can secure your code using a merge queue, automatically merge it, and many more features. By saving time, you and your team can focus on projects that matter.
Mergify是一个针对GitHub的工具，它可以对你的拉取请求（pull request）进行优先级排序、调整、自动合并、评论、变基（rebase）、更新、打标签、向后移植（backport）、关闭和分配。Mergify的功能允许你将平时需要手动完成的事情自动化。你可以使用合并队列（merge queue）来保护你的代码，自动合并它，还有更多功能。通过节省时间，你和你的团队可以专注于重要的项目。
Mergeify can coordinate with any CI and is fully integrated into GitHub. They have a startup program that could give your company a 12-month credit to leverage Mergify. That's up to $21,000 of value. Start saving time. Visit Mergify.com to sign up for a demo and get started. Or just follow the link in the show notes. Back to the episode. I have some questions, but I guess, yeah, so to like, to kind of bridge that back,
Mergify可以与任何CI（持续集成）协调，并完全集成到GitHub中。他们有一个初创公司计划，可以为你的公司提供12个月的信用额度来利用Mergify。这高达21,000美元的价值。开始节省时间吧。访问Mergify.com注册演示并开始使用。或者直接点击节目说明中的链接。回到节目。我有一些问题，不过我想，是的，为了把话题引回来——
what I hear you, you kind of calling out is, and I've observed this across many tasks, is that the last thing you want to do, and we talked about context switching, and that is you're ready to go do something, you hit compile. And then, you know, 10 minutes later, when you've awkwardly, like, I don't know what to do, check Slack, whatever, compile. And then, you know, 10 minutes later, when you've awkwardly, like, I don't know what to do, check Slack, whatever, your code comes back, oh, you, you know, you have a typo. You're like, oh, crap, you're like trying to figure out whatever, right? And so that, you know, when you have those friction points, then, you know, it just, it just, it kills more than just the time lost. So if I hear what you're saying is infrastructure code
我听到你的呼吁，我也在许多任务中观察到这一点，那就是你最不想做的事情——我们讨论过上下文切换——就是你准备好去做某事时，你点击了编译。然后，你知道的，10分钟后，当你尴尬地不知所措，比如，检查Slack什么的，编译完成了。然后，你知道的，10分钟后，当你尴尬地不知所措，比如，检查Slack什么的，你的代码回来了，哦，你发现，你知道的，你有个拼写错误。你会想，哦，该死，你就像是在琢磨别的什么，对吧？所以，你知道的，当你遇到这些摩擦点时，你知道的，它不仅仅是浪费时间，它扼杀的东西更多。所以，如果我理解你的意思，基础设施即代码
is in part to do this, that like you get ready to go deploy. And then there's these tasks that need to be done to make sure that in exactly the same way. So not only is it a tedious task, it's a task that needs to be done accurately, precisely, repeatably. And if you have a human do that, they're going to be context switched out, they're going to be frustrated, and you're going to lead into those problems that just take them out of their comfort zone, out of their flow, right? And like, put them into doing this task. And so this infrastructure at Code, you were sort of describing as helping solve that process to help like kind of go in and address it. I love so much that recap of what I just said, Patrick. It's like it was a complete, like a lob, a total softball. I mean, because that allows, so now I get to take
部分就是为了解决这个问题，就像你准备去部署一样。然后有些任务需要完成，以确保一切以完全相同的方式进行。所以它不仅是一项枯燥的任务，而且是一项需要准确、精确、可重复完成的任务。如果你让一个人来做这件事，他们的上下文就会被切换，他们会感到沮丧，而你就会陷入那些让他们脱离舒适区、脱离心流的问题中，对吧？然后让他们去处理这个任务。所以你刚才把这种基础设施即代码描述为有助于解决这个过程，以帮助介入并解决它。帕特里克，我太喜欢你对我刚才所说内容的总结了。这就像是一个完美的抛球，一个完全的软球。我的意思是，因为这使得，现在我可以接管
the other side, like the leadership management side, if you think about it. So, you know, I love, I don't know if you in the audience picked this up, but Patrick said one really cool thing is not only is this tedious job that you have to do, and it's done, you know, manually a lot of times, but it has to be absolutely bulletproof, repeatable automation. And it screams. And when you hear that, you know, something has to be done reliably, fast, and 100% of the time done the same way, you think scripting. And when you don't do scripting, you've identified a task that is going to wear down a developer's soul.
另一面，比如领导力管理方面，如果你仔细想想的话。所以，你知道的，我喜欢——我不知道听众里有没有人注意到这一点——但帕特里克说了一件非常酷的事，这不仅是一项你必须完成的枯燥工作，而且很多时候它是手动完成的，但它必须是绝对坚不可摧、可重复的自动化。而且它显而易见。当你听到这个时，你知道某事必须可靠、快速且百分之百以相同的方式完成，你就会想到脚本编写。当你不用脚本编写时，你其实已经发现了一项会消磨开发者灵魂的任务。
Oh, and one more thing I want to say about that is we're assuming that the developer has the necessary skills to build that infrastructure. But that's the rub. We're putting things on the developer that are not their responsibility. Is the environment hardened? Do they have a security opening? Did they conform to their corporate standards in getting the subnet correctly on? These things, you're paying a fully baked rate for a developer to figuring out something that they, there's a skills gap there. If we could somehow, what IAC does, it does another thing for leadership. It's taking a, there's a position typically held by a cloud architect that is responsible for those environments to be created properly, but they're, they number in the few and to make their skills scalable, you, if you put infrastructure as code, they can review scripts and not thousands of individual environments that they would have
哦，关于这一点，我还想说一件事，那就是我们假设开发者具备构建该基础设施所需的必要技能。但这才是难点所在。我们把不属于他们责任的事情压在了开发者身上。环境加固了吗？他们有安全漏洞吗？他们在获取子网时是否符合企业标准？这些事情，你支付给开发者全额薪酬，却让他们去搞清楚一些他们并不擅长的事情，这里存在技能差距。如果我们能以某种方式——IAC（基础设施即代码）所做的事，它对领导层还有另一个作用。它承担了通常由云架构师担任的职位，他们负责正确创建这些环境，但他们的人数寥寥无几，为了让他们的技能可扩展，如果你引入基础设施即代码，他们就可以审查脚本，而不是他们积压工作中的成千上万个独立环境。
on a backlog. So it's like a double win for both the developer and the leadership and it's setting and what infrastructure as code also sets up, sets the leadership up for is taking more stuff off of the off the developers plate. For instance, as a developer, I really am trying to get code out. I shouldn't care about the cloud bill. But to my developers that are listening on the call, on the podcast, you know you have that. At the end of the month, the manager comes up and says,
所以这对开发者和领导层来说是一个双赢的局面，而且基础设施即代码也为领导层做好了准备，那就是从开发者手中拿走更多的事情。例如，作为一个开发者，我真的只是想把代码发布出去。我根本不在乎云账单。但是对于正在收听电话会议、播客的开发者们，你们知道会有这回事。到月底，经理走过来问，
why did my cost spike suddenly? And then comes the activity of trying to figure that out. That kills me. I don't care. That's your job to figure out. I just write code. Yeah, that may actually not be obvious to people how that works. But a lot of large companies and the ones that don't do end up having someone need to kind of basically review the bill.
为什么我的成本突然飙升？然后就开始了试图弄清楚原因的活动。这简直要了我的命。我不在乎。那是你该去弄清楚的工作。我只负责写代码。是的，人们可能并不清楚这到底是怎么运作的。但是很多大公司，以及那些没有这样做的公司，最终都需要有人来基本上审查账单。
Because what they found out is if you don't hold them accountable the bill will just skyrocket and so um having been through companies going through that transition and so you're when you're going in and using a cloud service internal external like you're not paying that bill you're just it's getting built to your company right but it's getting built to some portion of your company and it's getting rolled up and rolled down and all that stuff happens and you're just using it. But then someone in your management chain will get an email at the end of the month or end of the week saying,
因为他们发现，如果你不对他们进行问责，账单就会急剧飙升。所以，嗯，经历过公司转型的人都会明白，当你开始使用内部或外部云服务时，你并不是在自己付账单，只是这笔账单被记在了你的公司名下，对吧？但它是记在你公司某个部门名下的，经过层层汇总和分摊，所有这些事情都会发生，而你只是在使用它。但随后你管理链中的某个人会在月底或周末收到一电子邮件，上面写着：
hey, here's how much you use. Here's how much has increased. Here's how much of year over year. I'm not telling you to make it go down, but I'm telling you, you should pay attention to it. I mean, at the very minimum, Patrick, it has context switched me. I have to now answer this question. I have to investigate.
嘿，这是你的使用量。这是增长的额度。这是年同比增长。我不是让你把它降下来，但我想告诉你，你应该关注一下。我的意思是，至少，帕特里克，这已经打乱了我的上下文切换。我现在必须回答这个问题。我必须进行调查。
But what IAC sort of gets us, infrastructure as code gets us, is there is, it doesn't get us all the way there, but right now I now have automation creating my infrastructure. Now, if your infrastructure is being created by automation, I can put in things called like tags, and I can guarantee that they will show up on my Amazon bill or my Azure bill or my GCP, my Google Cloud Compute bill. Now, that's not 100%.
但IAC（基础设施即代码）带给我们的是——基础设施即代码带给我们的是，它虽然不能完全解决所有问题，但现在我的基础设施是由自动化创建的。现在，如果你的基础设施是由自动化创建的，我就可以加入诸如标签（tags）之类的东西，我可以保证它们会显示在我的亚马逊账单、Azure账单或GCP（谷歌云计算）账单上。当然，这还做不到百分之百。
And I'm going to take a second just to plug, you know, the company that I work for, Quali Torque, Quali has a product called Torque, and we're a control plant, sort of over that. So and all I'm calling out here with this plug is IAC isn't all the way there. It's, you need a process to manage just like code stored in Git isn't all the way there. You need something to sort of act as a control plane and manage that. That's what GitHub is to get repos. You need something over IAC scripts, Terraform scripts floating around in your corporation. That's not going to help you. If somebody reuses that script with your tags on it, you'll get billed for that stuff, even though you're on another project. And so what we thought of is, what's the next step to make this problem go away and to
我想花一秒钟时间来推销一下我工作的公司Quali Torque。Quali有一款名为Torque的产品，我们在某种程度上充当其上的控制平面。所以，我在这里做这个广告想说明的是，IAC并不是万灵药。它——就像存储在Git中的代码还远远不够一样，你需要一个流程来管理它。你需要某种东西来充当控制平面并对其进行管理，正如GitHub之于Git仓库一样。你需要对企业中四处流传的IAC脚本、Terraform脚本进行管理。如果不这样做，对你毫无帮助。如果有人在其他项目上重用了带有你标签的脚本，你还是会被收费。所以我们思考的是，解决这个问题的下一步是什么？
satisfy both leadership and line working developers? And that's it. It's the control plane that says, I have a list of Terraform scripts or Helm scripts here. We divided up access to different applications, and you can provision all you want in a self-service way. And I can only touch the scripts that I care about, and it auto tags and auto does all that. So now as a developer, I get the environment that I want, and I never have to worry about costs. I never have to worry whether it meets corporate standards because the scripts have been signed off on and now are made available for reuse. And I don't have to worry about permissions.
如何同时满足领导层和一线开发人员的需求？就是这个。控制平面，它说：这里有一份Terraform脚本或Helm脚本的清单。我们将不同应用程序的访问权限划分开来，你可以通过自助服务的方式进行任意配置。我只能接触我关心的脚本，并且它会自动打标签、自动完成所有这些操作。现在，作为一个开发者，我可以获得我想要的环境，再也不用担心成本问题。我再也不用担心它是否符合企业标准，因为脚本已经得到批准，现在可以重复使用了。我也不用担心权限问题。
I, as a developer working on application A, will only be able to see certain scripts. And that's what really I'm trying to sort of nudge us towards. Like, let's stop making this a problem. Let's automate it. Let's give leadership the information they need and developers the ability to just, their fully baked cost is incredible. We want to trust them. If we don't trust them, that's more of an employee
我作为一个从事应用程序A开发的开发者，将只能看到某些脚本。这正是我真正想引导大家去做的方向。让我们停止把这变成一个问题。让我们把它自动化。让我们给领导层提供他们所需的信息，并赋予开发者只管写代码的能力——他们全面开发出的价值是不可思议的。我们想要信任他们。如果我们不信任他们，那更多就是一个员工HR问题，对吧？
HR problem, right? Let's stop snooping on them. Let's stop micromanaging them. Let's give them the tools that satisfy leadership's valid need for control and compliance and security with the ability to self-service develop. That's the holy grail, right? Maybe I'll express my naivete here. Okay, I definitely will. I have no idea what's going on.
让我们停止监视他们。让我们停止微观管理他们。我们要赋予他们工具，在满足领导层对控制、合规和安全的合理需求的同时，还具备自助开发的能力。这才是圣杯，对吧？也许我在这里表现得太天真了。好吧，我绝对是的。我完全不知道发生了什么。
So what i'm understanding in the flow is if i'm a developer and i'm trying to stand up some infrastructure and i can write these scripts you mentioned this terraform home script i'm not sure the difference but there are these two ones and then the idea being that like when we stand it up we want to associate that the things that we're bringing up are uh able to be grouped later so you can analyze them so you have these these tags you put on it you bring your stuff up i imagine you're saying how many of the thing you want like i need x number of processors i want you know x amount of i don't know bandwidth or an engine x you know proxy in front that's gonna do this is this the
所以我的理解是，如果我是一个开发者，我正试图搭建一些基础设施并且我可以编写这些脚本——你提到了这个Terraform、Helm脚本，我不太清楚它们的区别，但总归有这两种——然后我们的想法是，当我们搭建它时，我们希望将我们启动的东西关联起来，以便以后可以将它们归类，这样你就可以对它们进行分析，所以你有这些可以打上去的标签，你启动了你的东西，我想你是在说你需要多少那个东西，比如我需要X个处理器，我希望你知道X数量的——我不知道——带宽，或者前面有一个Nginx代理来做这件事，这就是那个
level am i kind of you totally got it. I did want to add one more thing. So we talked about the grouping logically. And we talked about doing that in tags. But another thing with the scripts, a lot of times just on their own, don't don't kind of address it's it's the lifecycle of infrastructure. A lot of these were just meant, hey, I gotta, I gotta stand this up fast. But you know, one of the ways that costs increase in the workplace for cloud causes, I forgot to kill an environment. Isn't that the dreaded one? Well, here with a control plan, and one of the things that we did was we took scripts and we say there is a lifetime. You set the lifetime at the beginning, and then it's guaranteed whatever assets were created by the
层面吗？我是这么理解的吗？你完全说对了。我还想补充一点。所以我们讨论了逻辑上的分组。我们讨论了在标签中这样做。但脚本的另一个问题是，很多时候仅靠它们本身，并不能解决基础设施的生命周期问题。其中许多脚本的初衷只是：嘿，我得赶紧把这个搭起来。但是你知道，云成本在工作场所增加的原因之一，就是我忘记销毁环境了。这难道不是最可怕的事吗？好吧，这里有了控制平面，我们所做的事情之一就是拿来脚本，然后设定一个生命周期。你在开始时设定生命周期，然后可以保证，无论由控制平面创建了什么资产，
control plan will be at that time when it's expired, it'll be killed. There's no I went over on the weekend, and I left a very expensive perf environment up. You know, there's none of that. So now, not only did I not have to worry about costs, but I can also confidently as an application team developer, I can confidently say I am reducing costs without it being a burden to me. It'll just die on its own in the time that I set. And I have the receipts to prove it. Nice. Okay. So I see this. This is addressing, yeah, we have this, you know, I mentioned this summary page comes out. Management's like, hey, what's this thing that's been running for this long? Does anyone know who owns it?
到了过期的时候，它们都会被销毁。再也没有什么“我在周末加班，然后把一个非常昂贵的性能测试环境留在那儿不管了”的情况发生。你知道，根本不会有那种事。所以现在，我不仅不需要担心成本，而且作为一个应用团队的开发者，我可以自信地说，我在降低成本的同时又没有给自己带来负担。它会在我设定的时间内自行消亡。而且我有收据为证。太棒了。好吧。我明白了。这解决了一个问题，是的，我们有这个，我提到过会有一份汇总页出来。管理层会说：嘿，这个运行了这么长时间的东西是什么？有人知道是谁拥有的吗？
We email around the team like, hey, who has this AWS instance running? Like, does anyone know what it is? Is it safe to take down? Like, we could take it down, but we don't know. Is it like serving some critical role? And like, you know, it's gonna... So what you're saying here is like,
我们在团队里发邮件到处问：嘿，谁在运行这个AWS实例？这到底是什么？有人知道吗？把它关掉安全吗？呃，我们把它关掉倒是可以，但我们不知道。它是不是在承担什么关键角色？而且，你知道，这将会——所以你在这里的意思是说，
not just, it helps with that as well. Not just like, hey, this is expensive and running, but where did it come from? How it get there who deployed it i mean are you getting that kind of like provenance information as well yes 100 and and also i mentioned um compliance and like okay we started talking about developer burnout and iac and those are sexy topics i'm about to talk about something super unsexy ready compliance? Compliance. I can just sort of picture all the folks listening. It's like, yeah, that is pretty, pretty unsexy. Tell us why though. I think actually a lot of people are going to be like, like personally, I've never
不仅如此，它在这方面也有所帮助。不仅仅是说：嘿，这个东西很贵而且还在运行，而是它从哪里来的？它是怎么到那里的？是谁部署的？我的意思是，你也能得到那种溯源信息吗？是的，百分之百。还有我提到的合规性，以及——好吧，我们开始谈论开发者倦怠和IAC，这些都是很性感的话题。我接下来要谈一个超级不性感的话题，准备好了吗？合规性。
run into compliance issues. So I don't want to talk about it because it sounds horrible, but I actually have no idea. Like does it actually actually be yeah i mean compliance for me just it sounds like a person with a suit who has like a two sort of pockets in his lapel and he's got the left pocket for left ear q-tips and the right pocket for right ear q-tips and never the two shall make you know one of these type of things you know okay so let's talk about compliance all right um folks on listening might remember there's a uh a lot of times software is built by you know taking uh public open source pieces of software like log4j and whatnot and recently we've heard about some very public you not mentioning any names, but very public, very embarrassing security breaches made.
合规性。我可以想象所有在听的听众。心想：是的，这确实挺、挺不生性感的。不过请告诉我们为什么。我想其实很多人会觉得——就我个人而言，我从来没遇到过合规问题。所以我不讨论它，因为它听起来太可怕了，但我其实根本不知道。它到底——是的，我的意思是，合规对我来说听起来就像是一个穿着西装的人，他的翻领上有两个口袋，左口袋放左耳棉签，右耳放右耳棉签，而且这两者绝不混用，你知道，就是这种类型的人，好吧，那我们来谈谈合规吧。好的，嗯，收听节目的朋友们可能还记得，很多时候软件是通过获取公共开源软件（如log4j之类）构建的，最近我们听说了一些非常公开的——不指名道姓，但非常公开、非常尴尬的安全漏洞。
And then when they root caused it, it was simply none of their software had a problem. It was software that they brought in that they depend on, such as a vulnerability in an older version of like say Log4j or something that's very popular and used by many. Compliance is making sure none of that happens. Somebody, so, you know, in the olden days, it would be somebody, we would have a BOM. It was called a BOM, B-O-M, a BOM list for software, like, oh, these are everything. And it was shrink wrap software, right? It was like a CD, you know, of, oh, here are all the files. And in the good old days, I could just check off all of these, you know, it's like, Oh, I know where this came from, whatever. And it's burned on CD for life. And it's no problem, right? Things have gotten much
然后当他们追查根源时，发现根本不是他们自己的软件出了问题。而是他们引入并依赖的软件，比如像Log4j旧版本中的漏洞，这种漏洞非常受欢迎且被许多人使用。合规性就是为了确保这些事情都不会发生。有人，所以，你知道，在过去的日子里，会有人，我们会有一份BOM。它被称为BOM，B-O-M，软件的BOM清单，哦，这些是所有的东西。那是预包装软件，对吧？就像一张CD，哦，这里所有的文件都在这。在过去的美好时光里，我可以勾选所有这些，你知道，就像，哦，我知道这个是从哪来的，诸如此类。而且它是一劳永逸刻录在CD上的。完全没问题，对吧？事情变得复杂多了，
more complicated in a connected, you know, open source, commercializing open source items, type of world. And so this is super important. And some of my colleagues in like, for instance, we have a partner, you know, JFrog makes one of the most popular artifact repositories there. And they offer that's so popular that they offer scanning all your binaries for you, and whatnot to see if you have any of those problematic dependencies. But the point here is the compliance is real. It's not going away. And if you go to any like DevOps, you know, conference, what they're going to talk about, they're constantly just like everything gets cheaper when you push it upstream in the development
在一个互联的、开源的、将开源项目商业化的世界里。所以这超级重要。我的一些同事，例如，我们有一个合作伙伴，JFrog，他们拥有那里最受欢迎的制品仓库之一。他们提供的服务太受欢迎了，以至于他们可以为你扫描所有的二进制文件等等，看看你是否有任何有问题的依赖项。但这里的重点是，合规是真实存在的。它不会消失。如果你去任何DevOps会议，他们都会谈论这一点，他们不断强调，当你把事情推到开发流程的上游时，一切都会变得更便宜，比如在思考和编写代码的阶段，他们开始这样做了，并称之为DevSecOps。他们把安全推向了食物链的上游。现在，不知道你们怎么样，反正我对安全一窍不通。好吧，我需要能帮我做到这一点的工具。而且我其实也不想去管。这就是我们在代码中所做的事情之一，你让一个云架构师负责这个，他们会确保你的Terraform脚本或Helm脚本是正确的。并且你要扫描所有的组件，确保基础设施满足要求。
process, like in the thinking and the coding part, they're going to start and they're calling it a DevSecOps. They're pushing security up the food chain. Now, I don't know about you, but I don't know jack about security. Okay, I need tools that are going to help me do this. And I don't really want to. And that's one of the things that we encode to you have a cloud architect responsible for this, they're going to make sure your Terraform scripts or your Helm scripts are correct. And you're scanning all the pieces and the infrastructure meets the requirements.
然后我们将其作为目录中的一张卡片发布，但这就是你的基础设施，超级酷的应用，1号QA基础设施或诸如此类。当你拥有这些卡片并运行它时，你就会知道合规已经完成了。因此，你消除了云架构师时间的瓶颈，你不需要雇佣多个人来做这事，只需一个人扫描所有脚本即可。而且你也省去了让开发者操心这些事的麻烦。第三，领导层很高兴，因为现在，你知道，你有了稳定性，你有了合规性，所有这些都有助于你赚钱。你知道，这是对你的软件没有崩溃、你不会陷入令人尴尬的公开事故的信心。所以控制平面以及引入你在这里完成的事情，
And so then we publish it as a card in a catalog, but this is your infrastructure, super cool app, number one infrastructure for QA or whatever. And when you have those cards and run it, you'll know compliance is done. And you therefore remove the bottleneck of your cloud architects time, you don't need to hire multiple of them to it's just one person scanning all the scripts. And you've also taken away the developer having to worry about this. And third, leadership is happy because now, you know, you have stability, you have compliance, and that all helps you make money. You know, it's confidence that your software is not broken, and you're not going to have an embarrassing, you know, public incident. So the so the control plane and bringing it in what you're accomplishing
是把更多的碎片组合在一起，并允许它们能够同时被查看。正如你所提到的，所有这些事情在某种程度上都是分散的，比如安全、合规、诸如此类，而你需要的是一个公共场所，正如你所说的，作为管理层，你希望能够去了解发生了什么；而作为开发者，你不想操心这些，你只想说：我把我的东西发布出去了。所以你试图做的是将所有这些东西聚合在一起，把它们放在一个公共场所，这样它们就可以真正地——我讨厌“协同效应（synergy）”这个词——但它们可以全部组合在一起，用到——不，不，不！每次我用这个词的时候我都气自己，感觉自己像个托儿，但是，
here is tying even more pieces together and allowing them to be sort of like view all all at the same time. Because as you're mentioning all these things are somewhat disparate like security compliance this that and what you need is a common place where as you said it's management you want to be able to go and know what's happening and as a developer you don't want to care you just want to say like i didn't get my stuff out and so what you're trying to do is sort of aggregate all those things together put them in a common place so that they can really just oh i hate that word synergy but they can all just sort of like combine to what to use it no no no i always get pissed out when i use it as i was being a shill but uh you
你知道，你把它们汇集在一起，你知道，就像——把它们一直放在一起更有意义，正如你所提到的，我的意思是，GitHub，对吧？在我看来，Git很酷，但你知道，版本控制你自己的同行评审流程，将所有这些整合到一个地方，并添加语法修正建议、同行评审注释以及自动化的Jenkins测试结果，对吧？把它放在一个地方，将Pull Request机制放在一个共同的地方，你知道，我本来要回应的，但我想帕特里克已经把该说的都说了，我只想让他也来和我一起工作，因为他说得比我还要好。让我们深入探讨一下这句话：控制平面并不是什么新鲜事，好吧。控制平面，你可以在技术文献中一直追溯到20世纪70年代。新鲜的是，我喜欢——我不知道我公司的其他人是否喜欢这个，但我喜欢把它和GitHub进行比较。表面上看，你会想，哦，GitHub听起来不像是一个那么复杂的软件，对吧？它只是一个在公共位置显示仓库的网页。任何人都可以做到这一点，但我认为人们没有抓住重点。那是一种需求。这是一种集中分散结构的需求。而在这里，我们正处于这种完全相同需求的风口浪尖。
know you bring it together and you know just sort of like it makes more sense to have them always like you mentioned i mean github right git was not in my opinion it was cool but you know version control your own peer review process bringing it all into one place and adding you know the syntax correction suggestions and the peer review comments and the automated jenkins test results right putting it in one place the pull request mechanism in one common place you know i was gonna respond but i think patrick said it all and i just want him to come work with me too because he said it better than than i could let's just like deep dive into that statement control plane is nothing new okay like a control
你拥有作为一场运动的DevOps，它在某种程度上解放了开发人员和运维人员，让他们按照自己想要的方式做事。但是当人们按照自己想要的方式做事时，在某个时候必须有一个——通常领导层扮演这个角色——一个真正的北极星，把所有的猫都朝同一个方向赶，对吧？这就是GitHub所做的。我很喜欢GitHub，因为它会让我的工作变得更轻松一点。我们正试图对基础设施做同样的事情。顺便说一句，这甚至不是一个新概念。你知道，我们谈论GitHub。但另一个类似控制平面的地方是Artifactroy，例如，针对二进制文件的控制平面。
plane you can find it in in technical literature all the way back into the 70s. What is new is like, and I like, I don't know if anybody else in my company likes this, but I like comparing it to GitHub. On the face of it, you think to yourself, oh, GitHub doesn't sound like that complicated of a piece of software, right? It's just a web page that's displaying repos in a common location. Anybody could have done this, but I think people are missing the point. It was a need. It was a need to centralize a decentralized sort of structure. And here we're on the precipice of that very same need.
这是一个人们共同解决以下问题的地方：他们拥有什么版本的二进制文件？它是否经过扫描并符合合规性？是否存在，你知道，他们发布报告，规定谁可以下载这些东西。我们一路走来都在做这件事。我的意思是，你知道，那些喜欢预测未来的人，去看看看清未来走向有多么容易。我们有存储在分布式版本控制系统Git中的代码，现在我们有了GitHub。我们在内部存储了二进制文件，现在我们有了Artifactory作为其上的控制平面。现在我们需要让基础设施不再成为瓶颈，我们将看到对该控制平面的需求。一个容纳所有东西的地方。一个领导层可以保证其审计、团队开发领导者可以确定谁对这些资产拥有权限的地方。
You have DevOps as a movement where you're sort of freeing developers and operation folks to do things how they want to. But when folks do things how they want to, there has to at some point be, and usually leadership plays this role, like a true north to get all of the cats herded in the same direction, right? And that's what GitHub does. And I love GitHub for it because it's going to make my job a little bit easier. We're trying to do that with infrastructure. And by the way, this isn't even a new concept. You know, we talk about GitHub. But another place that is a control plane like that is Artifactory, for example, for binaries.
最后，我们讨论的是开发者和避免职业倦怠。我再也不需要打开DevOps工单来获取我的QA环境了。顺便说一句，我们来谈谈这个。当我们手动完成这项工作，并把这个扔给DevOps来为我们配置文件环境时，我很乐意听听来自听众的反馈。
It's a common place where people are addressing what version of their binary do they have? Did it scan and meet compliance? Is there, you know, they publish reports, permissions of who can download that. And we've done this all along the way. And I mean, you know, folks who are into predicting the future, like, check out how easy it is to see where the future is going. We had code stored in a distributed version control system, Git, and now we have GitHub. We had binary stored internally, and now we have Artifactory being a control plane over that. And now we have the need for infrastructure to stop being a bottleneck, and we're going to see that there is a need for that control plane. One place for it all. One place where leadership can guarantee its audits, team development leaders can determine who has permissions to these assets.
在你的一生中，这成功过多少次？第一次交回来的时候，DevOps工单返回了，上面写着，哦，你完成了。它管用吗？我甚至连不上SSH。别想了。你知道，所以它将是一个迭代的过程，你必须去做。我希望能听到大家的反馈，如果需要打开工单来启动一个环境的话。我估计至少需要一周时间你才能拿到环境，你知道，有本事用事实证明我错了，这就是我想说的。是的，我的意思是，这一切都讲得通。所以我的意思是，我觉得我们已经把它解释得很好了。你知道，我想确保我们把握好你的时间。所以给我们讲讲，
And finally, we're talking about the developers and avoiding burnout. I don't ever have to open up a DevOps ticket to get my QA environment. By the way, let's talk about that. When we do this manually and when we throw this on DevOps to provision us an environment, I would love to get feedback from
你刚才提到——我的意思是，我想我们已经得到暗示了——Quali究竟是怎样介入并提供帮助的？他们做了什么来试图解决你指出的这种需求？哦，是的，非常感谢。我一直在暗示这一点。这一切都围绕着控制平面。但让我从公司的官方口径开始，然后深入到我最热衷的部分。但是，是的，我们正在为基础设施实现GitHub和Artifactory那种控制平面。我们讨论过那些支柱，对吧？所以有开发者的自助服务。
the audience. How many times in your life has that ever worked? The first time it was presented back, DevOps ticket comes back, it's like, oh, you're done. Does it work? I can't even SSH into it. Forget about it. You know, so it is going to be iterative, you're going. Does it work? I can't even SSH into it. Forget about it. You know, so it, it's, it is going to be iterative, you're going to have to do it. And I would love to hear back from people if there's a ticket needed to open up to start an environment. I'm thinking it's going to be at least a week before you get an environment, you know, prove me wrong, you know, is what I want to say. Yeah, I mean, I, it all makes sense. So I mean, I think we set it up pretty good. You know, I want to make sure we take your time. So tell us a little bit about like,
有基于角色的访问控制。这是为了开发、领导层和DevOps团队。还有可审计性和成本控制，这些都是领导层关心的所有事情。我们正试图把这些放在一个——不是试图，我们已经把这些放在了一个地方，并且我们希望大家来告诉我们他们的使用体验。
so you were kind of mentioning, I mean, I think we got the hint here, but where is quality trying to come in here and help? And like, what are they doing to kind of try to address this need that you're pointing out? Oh, yeah, like, thank you so much. So I have been hinting at it. And it is all about the control plan. But let me just like, I'll start off sort of with the corporate line. And then I'll just sort of drill into, you know, where I'm most passionate about. But yeah, we're fulfilling that GitHub and that Artifactory sort of control plane for infrastructure. And there are the pillars that we talked about, right? So there's self-service for developers.
我希望这将是颠覆性的。好吧，现在这是雄心勃勃的部分。这是罗纳克（Ronak）的心里话。我希望这基本上是无法区分的。Quali的Torque控制平面与基础设施即代码密不可分，就像GitHub和Git几乎密不可分一样。有些人说，是的，我在使用GitHub，或者我有一个GitHub仓库。这就好比，这是一个托管在GitHub上的Git仓库。我想让人们犯同样的错误，犯同样的混淆，因为我坚信，除了对我有选择的工作地点有利之外，我相信这实际上是一项能造福人们的事业。如果他们有不同的感受，或者没有看到他们想要的东西，这里有一个指引方向的机会。我希望参与并使用这个控制平面的人能够思考这将如何让他们的生活变得更好。因为如果它能让他们的生活变得更好，它可能也会让所有用户的的生活变得更好。这就是其中一种方式。
There's a role-based access controls. That's for development and leadership and DevOps team. There's auditability and cost control, all things that leadership care about. And we're trying to put that in one, not trying, we've put that in one place and we're looking for folks to, you know, come tell us what their experience is with that.
而且，你知道，这有点像给汽车调校。你知道，这就好像是，好吧，我调校了一辆车，我在里面加了个涡轮增压器。这就好像是，我要找到下一个需要帮助的部件，对吧？让我们搞定基础设施即代码，然后转向下一个问题。太棒了。所以Quali构建了这个Torque控制平面。控制平面，他们正在努力帮助解决这些
I'm hoping it'll be transformed. Okay, now here's where it's the aspirational. Here's where, this is Ronak talking about this. I'm hoping that this basically is indistinguishable. Quali's Torque control plane is indistinguishable from infrastructure as code the same way as GitHub and Git are almost indistinguishable. Some people say, yeah, I'm using GitHub or I have a GitHub repo. It's like, well, it's a Git using GitHub, or I have a GitHub repo. It's
事情，我的意思是，你就在那里，显然你认为这是一个非常值得做的事情。给我们讲讲Quali作为一家公司的情况，在里面工作感觉如何？你觉得他们是否在给开发者提供避免职业倦怠的机会？——不是故意给你挖坑，但你知道，这是我发现的事情之一，你知道，这也是我意识到我不喜欢撒谎的原因，因为谎言有太多细节要记住。所以我喜欢在不需要伪装自己的地方工作。这有时会给我惹麻烦。但我喜欢在那些与我的世界观契合、志同道合的地方工作。我个人，
like, well, it's a Git repo that's being hosted over there in GitHub. And I want people to make that same sort of funge, that same mistake, because I'm convinced that in addition to it benefiting my chosen place of work, I believe this is actually something that's going to help benefit people. And if they feel different, or if they don't see what they want, here's an opportunity to sort of direct that. And I want folks who participate and use this control plane to think how this is going to make their life better. Because if it's going to make their life better, it's going to probably make all of our users' lives better. And this is like one way.
好吧，首先，Quali位于美丽、阳光灿烂的得克萨斯州奥斯汀，在域名区域内，你绝对不会出错。所以，你知道，这只是一个超级酷的地方，我们正在做一件重要的事情，我认为。如果你深入了解并觉得这对你也很重要，那就来和我们聊聊。我们确实——如果你看看我们的公司历史，我们一直在努力解决这个问题。
And, you know, it's kind of like tuning up a car. You know, it's like, all right, I tuned up a car, I put a turbo in it. It's like, I'm going to find the next part that needs help, right? Let's nail infrastructure as code and let's move on to the next problem. Nice. So Quali has built out this TorqueDisk control plane. control plane they're you know trying to help with this
而且它几乎是不可分割地——我不会说那个词。我真的试过了。我试过说那个词。不可分割地？是的。
stuff i mean you you're there obviously like you think this is a this is a worthwhile wild thing tell us maybe a little bit about quali as a company how to work for it like do you feel are they giving their developers a chance to avoid burnout uh not not trying to set you up but you know it's one of the things I discovered, you know, like, it's sort of how I came upon that realization that I don't like lying, because that's too much to remember. So I like working for places where I don't have to parse myself. It gets me in trouble sometimes. But I work for places that are, you know, sort of like mine that fold in with my worldview. And I personally,
谢谢。我刚刚忘了。没关系。这很正常。今天是星期一。太星期一了。快来看看我们吧。有一些方法，反馈很重要。
okay, so first of all, location quality is located in the beautiful, sunny Austin, Texas, you can't go wrong with that in the in the domain area. So, you know, just super cool place to be, we're working on something that matters. I think. And if you take a look inside and you feel that this matters to you too, come talk to us. And we really, that's, if you look at our company history, we are trying to solve this problem.
如果你不想为我们工作，你可能会觉得，哦，那承诺有点太大了。那就去试试Torque吧。大家还记得旧的Discount Tire轮胎广告吗？如果你不喜欢你的轮胎，来告诉我们感觉如何。你看到一个老太太把轮胎扔过玻璃，那就来把轮胎扔过我们的玻璃幕墙吧。不是字面意义上的，请。好吧，好吧，我想不是字面意义上的。我可不想煽动什么骚乱。是的，就是这样。哦，还有，就我个人而言，我很乐意——就我个人的部分而言，我想听听你的经历。而且我知道在我们解决这个问题之后，下一个领域将是持续测试，我们也必须去解决这个问题。所以你有一个未来。这就像给汽车调校一样，我们只是要找到下一个需要它的地方。一旦我们把所有东西都纳入控制平面的保护伞下，我们将为人们提供解决所有这些未来问题的框架。我的意思是，这听起来太棒了。我的意思是，对于
And it's almost inextricably, I can't say that word, tied in with developer brand. I really tried. I tried to say that word. Iably, I can't say that word, tied in with developer brand. I really tried. I tried to say that word. I just couldn't. Inextricably? Yes.
想要尝试的人，你们有免费计划吗？有什么方法可以让人们试用Torque，或者他们可以访问的网站吗？百分之百。你知道的，就是 portal.qtorque.io/join。你可以注册一个免费层级并体验它，而且它是免费的。我非常坚持认为，你知道，它应该是免费的，因为我坚信，如果我期望得到回报，我就应该先付出有价值的东西。我很乐意——我只是请求反馈。太棒了。是的。
Thank you. I just forgot. It's okay. It happens. It's Monday. It's so Monday. Come check us out. There are ways to, feedback is important.
我的意思是，你知道，一定要去看看。我们会在节目文稿中附上链接。这真是一次非常棒的经历，我的意思是，我们涉及了很多领域。我觉得可能有很多问题，人们会带着这样的感慨离开：哇，这是一次关于基础设施即代码的旋风般的巡礼。听完我都觉得心力交瘁了。
If you don't want to work for us, you're like, oh, that's a little too much commitment. Try out Torque. Do you guys remember the old discount tire commercials? If you don't like your tires, come tell us how it feels. You see an old lady throw a tire through the glass, come throw a tire through our glass pane. Not literally, please. Well, okay, yeah, I guess not literally. I don't want to incite any riots. Yeah, that's it. Oh, and, and personally, I would love to and just the personal part of me, I you know, I want to hear about your experience. And I know where that next place after we nail this problem, it's going to be continuous testing, we're gonna have to, we're gonna have to address that, too. So you have a future. This is just like tuning up a car, we're just going to be continuous testing we're going to have to we're going to have to address that too so you have a future this is just like tuning up a car we're just going to find the next place that needs it and once we have it all under the umbrella of a control plane we're going to give folks the framework to address all these future problems as well i mean it sounds awesome i mean i think for
不，不，求你了，希望你听完没有筋疲力尽。我的意思是，你知道，很多事情都有助于我们及早开始。我的意思是，这不言而喻，但是，意识到无论是为公司、工具还是软件解决问题时存在的问题，
people trying it out, do you guys have like a free plan, a way for people to try Torque, a website that they can go to? 100%. It is, you know, portal.qtorque.io forward slash join. And there's a free tier that you can sign up for and think about it and it's free. And I was very adamant that, you know, it should be free because I fully believe in like, you know, giving something of value if I expect to get something. And I would love to just, I ask for feedback. That's awesome. Yeah.
还是职业倦怠，都是至关重要的。我的意思是，真正密切关注事情发展的方向，并确保你管理好技术债务或个人债务——确保你真正掌控全局，这将是我给人们的临别忠告，我想是的。好吧，非常感谢邀请我来。欢迎再次邀请我来，我们可以谈得更深入。
I mean, I think, you know, definitely check it out. We'll have the link in the show notes. And this has been a really awesome, I mean, we covered a lot of ground. I feel like probably a lot of questions, people are going to be left like, wow, there was a whirlwind tour of infrastructure as code. I feel burned out listening to it.
我们可以开始讨论，好吧，当你开始摆脱这种职业倦怠时，作为一名开发人员或技术工作者，你打算做什么来实现真正的自我？你打算做什么来让这个地方——实现真正的自我？你打算做什么来让这个地方写出更好的代码在个人时间？我们可以——或者这样如何？我们可以，你知道，每个图书馆都有你可以预订的房间，为什么不举办一个STEM之夜，传授一些你的编程技能，甚至只是教一个孩子如何使用Git，你知道，你会在当地找到新的让孩子们恨你的方法。
No, no, please, hopefully you're not burned out listening to it. I mean, I think, you know, a lot of these things and it helps us start early. I mean, I mean, it's, I guess it goes without saying, but, you know, realizing there's an issue both when you're problem solving for building a company or a tool or software,
是的。我最后直接被雷到了。我完全没有准备好。所以，你知道，我要说的是，我认为这真的很重要。你多次提到这一点，我们有很多原因感到非常荣幸。我的意思是，谈到——我想有时候我看到人们在我住的地方开车，有很多建筑工人，我看到人们在炎热的天气里工作，我就会想，哦天哪，我的职业倦怠和在炎热的夏日里搬运两块四（木材）相比，完全是两码事。所以我认为我们很幸运，而且你讲过一个故事，罗纳克，关于你的父亲是一名工程师，并且手头有那些书可以用来解答问题。我想说我的父亲是一位工程师，你知道，但有许多孩子有这种心态，但他们
but also burnout. I mean, being really attentive to the direction something is headed and making sure that you manage technical debt or personal debt, like making sure that you're really on top of the ball would be a parting admonition I would give people, I guess. Well, thank you so much for having me over. Have me back over and we can go even meta.
没有生活，书架上没有书供他们去探索，没有人在他们写在纸上的Fortran代码中指出错误或破解它，对吧？就像他们没有——不，要友善，要友善。但是，你知道，我认为这是一个很好的观点，试图帮助那些人，并把那些人带进来，你知道，我们有时会在播客中收到人们写信给我们，嘿，你帮我进入了科技行业。我的意思是，现在我们做这件事已经够久了。其中一些人现在已经在职业生涯中走得很远了。这真的能帮你感受到那种回报感，就像你说的，真正找到一个人，在有人告诉你时把接力棒传下去——帕特里克，难道这不会让你的这一天都变得美好吗？这就是我们在
We can start talking about, okay, when you start getting rid of this burnout, what are you going to do as a developer or as a tech worker? What are you going to do to actualize that true self? What are you going to do to make this place that true self? What are you going to do to make this place better code on personal time? We could or or how about this? How about we can, you know, every library has, you know, rooms that you can like reserve, why not host like a STEM night and pass on some of your coding skills, just even showing a kid how to use Git, you know, you'll find new ways for kids to hate you in the area.
这个播客中所谈论的，我们讨论了开发人员的职业倦怠，这有点像——我在脑海中把它等同起来。这有点像，哦，好的，我正在帮助车祸现场的人，对吧？而在这里，解决开发人员的职业倦怠更像是，我给某人上了一条止血带，好吗，来止血。但我们需要更多的帮助。我们在现场确实需要实际的帮助。但没关系。我们会活下来，我们会一起度过难关。然后你会，你知道，无论是在几个月后还是一年后，我们都会讨论下一阶段的发展。
Yeah. I was completely killed at the end. I was not ready for that. So, you know, I'll say that I think that's really important. And you mentioned this several times, like, we're really privileged for a lot of reasons. I mean, talking i think of you know i see sometimes people driving around where i live there's lots of construction i see people out working in the heat and i think about like oh my gosh like my burnout is an entirely different beast than you know hauling around two by fours in the you know hot summer day so i think we're privileged and i think you said a story ronak about your father being an engineer and sort of like having those books available answering questions i'd say my father was an engineer you know but there are many kids out there that like have the mindset but they they
是的。最后我彻底被击垮了。我对此毫无准备。所以，你知道，我会说我认为这真的很重要。你多次提到这一点，比如，由于很多原因，我们真的很幸运。我的意思是，说到这儿，我想起你知道的，我有时看到人们在我住的地方开车到处转，有很多建筑工地，我看到人们在烈日下工作，我会想，天哪，我的职业倦怠与在炎热的夏日里搬运木方完全是两码事。所以我觉得我们很幸运，罗纳克，你讲过一个关于你父亲是一名工程师的故事，家里有那些书可以用来解答问题。我的父亲也是一名工程师，你知道，但外面有很多孩子，他们有这种心态，但他们
don't have a live they don't have a book on the bookshelf for them to discover they don't have someone to come up and point the flaws in their Fortran code they wrote on paper or break it, right? Like they don't have, no, be nice, be nice. But like, you know, I think this is a great point, like trying to help those and bring folks in who just, you know, we get sometimes to the podcast where people write us, hey, you helped me get into tech. I mean, now we've been doing it long enough. Some of those people are already like well into their careers now. And it really helps you feel that sense of like you said giving back really finding someone to kind of pass the baton to when when somebody tells you that patrick doesn't it just it doesn't it just make your day and that's that's what we're
没有生活，书架上没有可供他们探索的书籍，没有人在他们写在纸上的Fortran代码中指出错误或帮他们纠错，对吧？就像他们没有——不，放客气点，放客气点。但是，你知道，我认为这是一个很好的观点，比如试图帮助那些人，把那些人带进来，只是，你知道，有时候我们在播客里收到人们写信来，嘿，你帮我进入了科技行业。我的意思是，现在我们做这件事已经够久了。其中一些人现在已经在他们的职业生涯中发展得很好了。这确实能让你感受到你刚才说的回馈感，真的找到一个可以把接力棒传下去的人。当有人对你这么说时，帕特里克，难道这不会——难道这不会让你的这一天都变得美好吗？这就是我们
talking about in this podcast we talked about developer burnout and that's kind of like I'm equating it in my mind. That's kind of like, oh, okay, I am helping somebody at a car accident, right? And here, addressing developer burnout is more like I have applied a tourniquet to somebody, okay, to stop the bleeding. But we're going to need more help. We're going to need actual help at the scene here. But that's okay. We're going to survive and we're going to do it together. And then you're going to, you know, be it months from now or a year from now, we're going to talk about the next phase to that
在这个播客中谈论的内容。我们谈论了开发人员的职业倦怠，我脑海中把这等同于：这就好像是，哦，好吧，我正在帮助车祸中的某个人，对吧？在这里，解决开发人员的职业倦怠更像是给某人上了止血带，好用来止血。但我们需要更多的帮助。我们需要现场的实际帮助。但没关系。我们会活下来，我们会一起度过难关。然后你会，你知道，无论是在几个月后还是一年后，我们会讨论接下来的阶段。
actualization and making things better. And I thank you guys for the extreme privilege it was to talk with you. Well, thank you everyone for listening in again, and we'll see you next time. Music by Eric Farndaller. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution uh to uh patrick and i and uh share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
实现自我并让事情变得更好。非常感谢你们给我这个极大的荣幸与你们交谈。好的，谢谢大家再次收听，我们下次再见。音乐由埃里克·法恩达勒创作。音乐由埃里克·巴恩·多勒制作。Programming Throwdown 采用知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，以及对其进行混音和改编，但你必须注明对帕特里克和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。